c'est comme un cri d'alarmé que pousse
le photographe romain gibier à travers
une série de clichés dans une série
nommée culture en danger il met en scène
des professionnels qui sont empêchés
d'exercer leur art car considérés comme
non essentiels lui-même et conteur et
ses spectacles sont à l'arrêt il publie
ses photos chaque jour sur sa page
facebook
elles sont par ailleurs affiché sur
certaines devantures de salles de
spectacles comme le bateau ivre
rencontre avec aurélie renault chloé et
loue son chansonnière à l'arrêt leur duo
s'appelle les faucheuses aujourd'hui
elles prennent la pose devant l'objectif
de romain gibier depuis plusieurs
semaines le photographe professionnel
enchaîne les séances pour son projet
culture en danger artistes techniciens
diffuseur tous les métiers sont
représentés sur ces clichés pour
l'exemple du magicien close up
effectivement alors on a représenté le
close up avec les cartes un peu partout
sur la table il est en train de tendre
une carte qui s'avère être l'as de coeur
sauf que on la barre et parce que
effectivement pour lui si je sais que
c'est un vrai crève coeur de ne pas
pouvoir travailler
voilà donc à chaque fois il ya un
message qui passe de cette façon là le
médiéviste il se sent comme assassiné
par la crise c'est pas pour rien qu'ils
allaient paix qui le traversent chaque
jour romain poste deux clichés
estampillé non essentielles sur les
réseaux sociaux
son objectif mettre en lumière la
détresse du milieu culturel
il est épaulé par la salle du bateau
ivre afin de multiplier les rencontres
avec l'ensemble des professionnels vous
montrer que le secteur culturel et le
milieu artistique à une pléthore de
métiers qui sont souvent inconnues
souvent dans l'ombre c'est ça va des
maquilleuses ça va des gens aussi qui
nettoie les salles ça va avec les
administrateurs
avec tous ces métiers qui sont pas
visibles pour que le spectacle vivant
existe le photographe lui-même compteur
dans une compagnie tourangelle veut
alerter le grand public sur la détresse
du secteur il espère voir ces clichés
s'afficher un peu partout comme ici sur
la façade du bateau ivre
en fait j interpelle à peu près toutes
structures culturelles qui veulent aussi
montrer la grogne est donc pouvoir
afficher
diffusez d'une autre façon moi j'ai un
centre socioculturel qui m'a contacté en
disant nous on n'a pas de place pour
afficher par contre la structure est
ouverte parce qu'on a une crèche qu'il
ya du monde qui passe nous on veut
mettre un écran avec un défilement de
photos ça peut être ça tous les moyens
sont bons ce qui est important c'est que
le message passe
romain gibier a déjà réalisé 70 clichés
localement et espère symboliquement
atteindre les 100 photos